comment tu dis ça une chocolatine une
chocolatine pain au chocolat les gars
c'est un pas au chocolat vous pouvez
aller dans le Sud-Ouest et en tant que
quelqu'un qui vous dit à ce que la
chocolatine je vous la mets dans une
poche une poche
ne soyez pas étonné si vous changez si
vous allez dans l'ouest de la France
d'entendre des mots qui peuvent parfois
gêner la communication puisque vous
venez de l'Est de la France par exemple
et que vous ne les comprenez pas je
m'appelle Mathieu avanzy et je fabrique
des cartes depuis 2015 des cartes qui
nous permettent de voir comment telle ou
tel objet change de nom en fonction des
régions de France de Suisse et de
Belgique avec les nouveaux médias de
plus en plus de jeunes sont enclins à
utiliser des mots régionaux qui sont
connus normalement a priori dans une
seule région on va prendre l'exemple du
cas de Marseille avec des mots comme
tarpins qui veulent dire beaucoup ou des
mots comme des gains qui veut dire
personne et ces mots ne viennent pas
alimenter le français général ils
viennent alimenter l'argot des jeunes
non seulement parce qu'il voit à la télé
ou aussi parce qu'ils entendent parce
que certains rappeurs sont origines de
la cité phocéenne on entend beaucoup de
gens qui s'appellent fratés ou Fradet
qui un mot Corse qui veut dire frère ou
sœur les mots régionaux ont différentes
origines il y a beaucoup de mots qui
viennent des patois ou des dialectes ou
des langues régionales comme on les a eu
appelés c'est-à-dire des langues parlées
nos ancêtres les noms de la fête foraine
donc si vous êtes dans la région
Rhône-Alpes vous appelez ça une vogue
jusqu'à Genève et puis si vous êtes dans
le sud de la France on dit fête votive
qui continue à un mot emprunter
l'occitan un mot qui était le mot vota
vous avez le réveil vous avez le festin
à Nice donc tous ces mots étaient
utilisés par les anciens en français
comme dans les langues régionales et
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus qu'utilisés
en français parce que c'est l'angle
régional ont souvent disparu
[Musique]
à part les mots qui viennent des
dialectes ou des langues régionales qui
étaient par les naguères il existe tout
un tas de régionalismes qui sont ce
qu'on appelle des innovations ou des
néologisme c'est-à-dire des mots qui
sont créés toutes pièces pour
correspondre à des nouvelles réalités
alors dans les années 70 quand les
premiers blancs correcteurs arrivent sur
le marché ils sont fabriqués en
Allemagne par une entreprise qui
s'appelait Tipp-Ex type veut dire verset
et ex veut dire revenir en arrière et
donc finalement par le commerce ou par
les usages notamment par les mouvements
qui a pu avoir dans les écoles le mot
tipex est resté à Paris il est resté
dans l'Est de la France mais dans le
reste de la France à l'Est on parle de
blanc dans l'ouest on parle de BLANCO un
kebab un Grec
des migrants comme par exemple bon
beaucoup de migrants italiens ou
espagnol dans dans les années après
guerre l'immigration maghrébine ou alors
l'immigration des différents pays
francophones d'Afrique aujourd'hui
donnent rarement lieu à la naissance de
régionalise puisque souvent les mots qui
découlent de ces populations sont
absorbées directement par
le français standard l'immigration
grecque qu'on a connu à Paris avec les
différents restaurants par méthodymie on
a appelé les sandwichs à la viande qui
vendaient des Grecs et c'est un usage
qui est connu seulement dans
l'Île-de-France dans la région
parisienne dans le reste de la France on
a adopté d'autres termes comme le mot
kebab et puis du côté de l'Alsace où il
y a une immigration turque beaucoup plus
importante et beaucoup plus focalisé on
a utilisé le mot donnèrent ou deux nerf
qui l'abréviation en fait de donneurs
kebab tout simplement pour certains mots
on arrive facilement à retracer leur
origine puisqu'on va chercher dans la
presse ou alors on va aller regarder
dans les journaux ou dans les romans qui
ont été publiés depuis qu'on parle
français depuis au moins le XVIème
siècle et puis on va essayer de voir bon
bah est-ce que ce mot existait dans tel
endroit quelle est sa trajectoire est-ce
qu'on le retrouve chez qui dans quelle
région etc et puis il y a d'autres gens
que nous qui ont travaillé sur des
dictionnaires des dictionnaires de
régionalise ou des lexiques ou des
traités de patois ou de langues
régionales ou de dialectes qui nous
permettent aussi de nous renseigner sur
l'état de la langue il y a un siècle de
siècle un crime à papier une mine une
mine un crayon de papier crayon à papier
des mots dans l'origine et flou
Descartes dont on n'arrive pas à
comprendre ou expliquer pourquoi on
retrouve telle ou tel géographique c'est
par exemple l'exemple du crayon ou du
crayon de bois avec ses variantes crayon
gris criant à papier crayon de papier
dont on a aucune idée d'où vient cette
dénomination il faut savoir que les
crayons de mines ou ces mines de
graphite existe seulement depuis le 18e
siècle et puis on a peu de ressources
qui nous permettent de dire pourquoi
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui sans doute à
cause de l'école sans doute à cause des
mouvements de population et des zones
mais d'où viennent ces dénominations on
en a aucune idée est-ce que ça continue
d'évoluer est-ce que certains mots vont
plus disparaître au contraire vont plus
gagner en influence dans d'autres
régions il y a énormément de mots qui
sont en train de disparaître alors quand
on interroge les grands-parents ou qu'on
interroge les personnes qui ont
aujourd'hui plus de 60 ans on peut voir
que ces personnes connaissent des mots
que les jeunes ne connaissent pas par
exemple les dénominations de la mâche
donc la masse c'est cette salade qu'on
consomme surtout en hiver qui
aujourd'hui s'appelle mâche un peu de
partout mais qui dans il y a quelques
années une vingtaine d'années trentaine
d'années ça appelait plutôt 12,7 dans
l'ensemble du sud de la France ce qui
touche également à la flore ou tout ce
qui touche à la faune par exemple dans
la région de l'Est on appelait Darbon
pour une taupe ou alors Caillon pour un
cochon sont des mots qui sont en train
de disparaître parce que ils désignait
surtout des réalités locales agricoles
paysannes aujourd'hui dans notre société
ces mots n'ont plus lieu d'être parce
que quand vous achetez un livre d'images
à des gamins il va lire cochon il va
lire taupe il va lire blaireau il va
plus trouver ta son etc des mots
régionaux donc tout ça explique que des
mots peuvent disparaître à l'inverse des
mots qui disparaissent il y a des
régionalistes qui s'étendent qui se
dérégionalisent le chalet désignait une
habitation typique des Alpes une petite
maisonnette en bois aujourd'hui tout le
monde connaît le mot chalet puisque que
le référent c'est lui-même exporté on a
le mot cagnard que certains
dictionnaires continuent de donner comme
régional mais cagnard qui désigne un
show une chaleur très étouffante
pourquoi ces mots se dérégionalisent
parce qu'ils ont ils rendent des
services si on veut
aux Français qui n'ont pas de mots qui
n'ont pas de concept précis sans passer
par des longues phrases ou des
périphrase pour désigner tel ou tel
objet c'est comme ça que fonctionne la
langue que les régionalismes peuvent
venir enrichir la langue française
jusqu'à jusqu'à terme que les
dictionnaires les donne comme sans
marque régionale et leur origine restera
toujours régionale c'est régionalisme
nous permettent comme les équipes de
foot ou comme certaines curiosités
touristiques de dire moi je viens de là
moi j'appartiens à cette communauté
[Musique]